number one I
I'm solid
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
we came all the way from our junior Oman
Tunisia Egypt and behind
[Music]
this experience has been amazing I've
learned I've met a lot of people and
there are a lot of things I've learned
how to work under pressure and it's been
a very unique experience that I wish I
can do again it's been great so far I'm
really proud of organizing team they did
a really good job and I'm really happy
to see all these motivated people in
here the experience was very amazing we
had a great team we worked hard I came
here to do network and to meet other
people we witnessed over a thousand
participants from over 30 countries
participating in the AI hackathon I'm
privileged and honored to be here be
part of this landmark event in Tunisia
it's the first of its kind in terms of
scale and in terms of content super
impressive people here are happy and
excited they are enjoying the challenges
we want to thank our sponsors and
partners who believe it on this event
they've only gotta win this challenge we
are here to win I'm here to win not to
participate sunshine you'll see me there
first place
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
I know a lot of people came from so many
places around the world to be with us to
sleep and do a speed had 80-plus amazing
teams and you had more than 450
individual competing on from Friday to
Saturday you have to remember this was
two hackathons in the same weekend so
when we talk about doing a 1,000
hackathon between the two of them
it's a did a lot of hard work and a lot
of amazing stories yesterday people are
working so hard that they had to go to
the hospital and then they have to come
back and win and be on the top tier and
be on the top 20 so I want to thank
everyone for coming and then we are
going to start very fast
so here the plan the plan is we have 10
teams each team will come pitch
40-minute the judges will ask couple
question we finished a minute and we go
to the next and after that we are going
to announce a lot of lot of prizes to
the individual competition and to the
starter with that I would love to thank
our esteemed judges I'm going to give
them like few not few minutes or give
them couple minutes to present
themselves we have amazing people we
have as I said this judging panel is a
reflection of all of you we have seven
different countries or and we have like
multiple continents and we have woman
and man so let's start with Kareem he's
our head of judges go ahead
[Applause]
thanks a lot for the intro Salim so I'm
Kareem Bagheera I'm the co-founder and
CEO of insta deep I'm also a Google
machine learning developer expert and a
member of the steering committee of deep
learning in dhaba Thank You Salim thanks
to every volunteer with us the last not
only three days but for the last month
really you've done amazing jobs
my name is Lionel Sahab I'm a Google
developer expert in product strategy and
G speed I'm the founder of bamboo geeks
and a digital consultant at McKinsey &
Company hello everybody
I - Rosie innovation director from
innovation city everything and thank
Google and that's the deep of course for
organizing this event and thank
everybody all the participants
hello Zara I'm Co father and CBN via
ovens too deep I want to thank everyone
who showed up everyone who helped
everyone who run around like crazy to
get this event to be what it is so thank
you everyone
hi everyone my name is Karim and I'm
founder and CEO of expansion one of the
subjects you had to try was beats our
recognition so I want to thank everyone
for participating and I want to add
something when I started expense here
five years ago one of my dreams was to
see something like this happen in
Tunisia so good job everyone I'm the
co-founder and Managing Partner of Bey's
ventures a venture capital firm out of
Muscat and just echoing everybody's
sentiment thank you all for making us a
reality and I look forward to see what's
next
[Applause]
hello everybody I want to thank at
welcome everybody who came to this event
especially those people coming from Arab
and African countries
I am Heights Missouri the general
director of innovation and technology
development in the Ministry of Industry
and SME thank you again hello everyone
my name is Rania Hamada and I am the
head of research and design for a team
called area 120 at Google and I have to
say this experience has been great the
pitches have been great and I wish good
luck to the 10 amazing teams that are
gonna come up here in pitch hi everyone
I pledge the Hammadi from Saudi Arabia
I'm a CEO for ticket Ron's company and
Google developer expert at product
strategy andy sweet and founder and
leader for dc-dc saudi arabia thank you
so much hello my name is Vivian Gomes I
am the founder and director co-founder
and director of human factor research
and design a company based out of
Bangalore we operate around the world
and partner with the Google ecosystem
for startups it's been an amazing event
so far wish everybody all the best
so thank you our steamed judges so with
that we are going to go ahead and start
with team one so again you have three
minutes
you do whatever you have to do to
convince our judges that you are the
best team here if you have technical
difficulty you should go if you want to
do a demo and doesn't walk take the demo
go downstairs talk to them do whatever
you have to do so with that waste of my
team number one just to give you some
background on those team there are ten
teams coming from five different
countries we have teams from Algeria we
have teams coming from Tunisia we have a
team coming from Egypt we have a team
coming from Jordan and we have a team
form oh man
so strategize
are you ready let's go let's go let's go
[Applause]
hello everyone are you doing so I'm
going to say start and then do whatever
you want a team in a two minute and a
half there would be the beep and the
flashes and the team minutes let's stop
the sale right judges should I count
down again three two one go hello
everyone so we are team strategize where
are the slides are there slides okay so
we are steam strategize and we want to
make a like environmentalism profitable
and sexy again so basically we're
talking about the idea of waste so
throughout the supply chain we have a
lot of waste that comes out from each
businesses so for example think about
the supermarket that so in America for
example in American supermarkets there
is 1/7 of the products they get wasted
just because the shelf lives they run
out and people don't buy it
so basically what ends up they just get
thrown away and this has been accounted
for about 15 billion dollars per year
only in US supermarkets so that's a lot
of money that can be saved so this will
cause a lot of strain on the on the
businesses they are losing a lot of
money and also it's destroying our
environment so if you try to model this
idea so basically we have the production
some part of it gets sold and the other
part gets wasted so if we are thinking
of like some kind of production that is
not data driven then we have a lot of
waste that is the distance between what
we are producing versus what is sold
however so if we are trying to decrease
that so basically that would be the
perfect solution what we are producing
exactly is everything that we are
selling but that's not really realistic
however we can try to reach something
like that so basically if we have a data
model that is driven based on the
previous data sales then we can predict
the data of the future ok
so then we can get something that is
actually will decrease the waste by
decreasing the production in order to
match it and then we are decreasing our
losses however so that's how the idea of
the strategize which we are trying to
make we are trying to make prediction
for the sales for the future for each
business on the other side we still have
a little bit of waste so we introduce
promo ties which will be an app that
gives real-time promotions for the users
so the remaining part that is going to
go to waste
usually businesses they strike it like
subsidized and so on so we are going to
send the our users discount and then
they are going to they can go to the
businesses so that they can get the idea
so our ecosystem goes like this we have
strategized that takes business data and
then they give them predictions so that
they can optimize their production
process and also we have promote eyes
which deals with the consumers and they
are actually getting real-time access to
promotions and these two can get
feedback from each other so that they
can update the model and give even
better solutions for businesses thank
you my question to you is like what's
the monetization model for your product
yeah so first part of monetization is
that we are giving a business to
business which is the stress model where
they're predicting their future sale and
that will we are trying to make them
save money in their production part or
for example also like storage and where
the mobile app as well
since source
to business while our business to
customer is more for like gathering data
in order to improve the model and also
maybe we can get as well some sentiment
analysis and reviews so we can give even
more services in order for like that for
the scalability part where we can maybe
recommend even new products or new
markets and so on ok any question from
the other judges so maybe could you be
more accurate like in terms of like is
it a subscription model is this a volume
based model yeah so actually we didn't
really actually thinking about we
thought about both of these ideas so
mainly we thought of more like of a
subscription model where the business
they start to give us data and they
start to update it and then what we give
them is a link to some sort of a web app
or like an application so that they can
start to see what is the projected input
in the next time and then they can also
update their data the other thing is
that if we're going if they're going to
go also for the promotion part then we
would ask them for a way or like a
connection to our network so that we can
get real-time data of their sales as
well ok have you spoken to customers
already so not yet because we started
like this part in the hackathon here we
got this idea and the hackathon here but
we have people who are already worked
with startups before so they already
have some clients but yeah we hope to
start already talking to businesses in
the next stage excellent
any more question
have you any competitors
so
and nano solution with with the
prediction model and how are you going
to convince customers the first customer
to give you data
you mean the